today we're making some simple silky egg  drop soup i'm making the cornstarch  slurry here used to thicken the soup  later in a pot i'm adding two cups of  chicken broth half can of sweet corn the  whites of one green onion and half a  teaspoon of white pepper while i wait  for this to come to a boil i crack two  eggs and beat them well back to our pot  i'll add the corn starch slurry and stir  making sure there are no lumps reduce  the heat and while slowly stirring pour  in your beaten eggs you'll wash them  create these beautiful ribbons lastly  add the sesame oil salt and the green  onions so comforting so delicious this  is one of those recipes that you can  dress up or dress down depending on your  mood it's so simple and versatile and  forever a classic